in december and you've said a couple of
times now that when the opportunity
presents itself you'll speak with
emmanuel macron but if you reached out
have you offered to
to have you tried to call him and speak
to him now and is he just not taking
your call yes we have and the
opportunity for that call is not yet but
we'll be patient we understand the
disappointment and that is the way you
manage difficult issues it's a difficult
decision it's a very difficult decision
and of course we had to weigh up what
would be the the obvious disappointment
to france but at the end of the day as a
government we have to do what is right
for australia and serve australia's
national security interests and i will
always choose australia's national
security interests
a couple of weeks ago australia the
united states and the united kingdom
announced a new security pact called
occus which will result in the three
countries collaborating in the
indo-pacific region
the announcement of august sets up a
financial and strategic loss for france
and also represents an increasing
investment by a subset of western
democracies in a specific region and it
looks like europe isn't being included
china's military is growing and it
currently has the largest naval force on
the planet in 2016 australia equipped
with submarines that were nearing their
end of service and also feeling the
growing pressure from china secured a 90
billion submarine deal with the french
naval defense contractor naval group and
this deal would give australia
possession of 12 shortfin
barracuda-based attack-class
diesel-electric submarines
the diesel as opposed to nuclear-powered
subs would have been cheaper to run and
maintain but they would have needed to
resurface more be smaller and would have
had a weaker propulsion system
the french deal became precarious after
a lack of demand for local australian
industry wasn't fulfilled along with
cost overruns delays and an increasing
demand for more powerful submarines
nuclear-powered subs can remain
submerged for longer amounts of time are
larger and are also more expensive but
when it comes to submerged propulsion
speed underwater nuclear power is simply
the better option the value of the
nuclear subs seems to have overweight
the value of the diesel ones and
australia has announced that their deal
with france is over as they put in a new
order with the united states for at
least eight nuclear-powered
hunter-killer submarines as part of
their new security pact
across the world are putting their
attention towards the indo-pacific a
pretty large place it's home to sixty
percent of the world's population
produces sixty percent of the global gdp
and it's also the second largest
destination for exports from the eu for
member states like france a country with
more than a million citizens in the area
as well as stationed troops their
objectives have been made clear france
wants to be a stabilizing force promote
the values of freedom in the rule of law
and help solve certain geopolitical
challenges
for the eu specifically by pivoting off
of individual member states own goals as
well as being primarily led by france
the eu has announced that they will
focus on reinforcing cooperation promote
a rules-based international order keep
open markets and ensure stable trading
environment however unfortunately for
them on the same day that the eu was set
to make their official announcement for
their indo-pacific strategy auckus was
also announced and that means that the
three countries that were already
notorious for being excessively loud
when it's not socially acceptable
decided to announce their own private
clubhouse in the indo-pacific region
overshadowing the eu's announcement and
forcing europe to reconsider their
overall strategy
mcclellan has already begun signaling
for a larger push in european
sovereignty saying things like europeans
must stop being naive when we are under
pressure from powers which at times
harden we need to react and show that we
have the power and capacity to defend
ourselves this statement happened
alongside a new defense pact announced
with greece where france will supply the
eastern european country with french
frigates supplied by of course naval
group
recently charles michel the european
council president also declared that
2022 will be the year of european
defense we want less dependency we want
more influence because we have values to
promote
next year france will also take over the
rotating presidency of the council
although this mainly grants france some
form of agenda setting it's already
clear that the french will set the focus
of their presidency on power and defense
with the european defense summit also
being led by mccomb in 2022
if there is any time to look at how a
european army might develop that time is
now
back in 2020 eu defense ministers began
working on a strategic compass for
security and defense the adoption will
happen in the first half of 2022
alongside france's presidency and in
that document we should be able to see
europe's vision not necessarily of the
entire population but definitely of
europe's political establishment for
what kind of security and defense actor
europe will be
common defense policies fall under
member states which means that they're
essentially gridlocked a single veto can
block its creation
although the adoption of the european
army is highly improbable now there are
steps that set a groundwork where it
becomes increasingly more likely
for example like in many other policy
domains europe has fragmented military
industries that can cause coordination
problems take for example card initiated
by the council of the european union by
2016 the coordinated annual review on
defense or card provides a comprehensive
picture of the european defense
landscape to member states for the first
time including capability research and
industrial aspects
the objectives of card are to analyze
national defense planning and
development to help member states
identify opportunities for cooperation
in critical areas and to serve as a
pathfinder for collaborative capability
development projects card has
recommended a joint development of
different military defense technologies
because a lack of coherence can have a
negative impact on the ability of member
states forces to operate together
efficiently an example of this is the
european main battle tank which is a
combination of military technology
between kraus maifai vekhman of germany
and nexter systems of france although
it's too early to say anything
substantial about how this will
contribute to european defense
concretely it's a clear example of how
fragmentation of the military in europe
can be changed
overall a construction of a european
army is likely to mirror other examples
of where europe has integrated small
incremental steps that make a larger
coordinated european policy that ends up
replacing national fragmentation seem
like it was always to be expected
you